[Applause]
this is danielle dimartino booth with
valuetainment economics
i'm bringing you today an audience with
jeffrey gundlach
founder of double line we're here in los
angeles
and we hope you enjoy our conversation
welcome
have you seen between two ferns okay i
have seen it i saw barack obama on it i
think
funny music zack guy right yeah just
reminded me of that but let's
let's start off with something serious
where were you
when scott norwood missed the field goal
in 1991
let's see i was in my family room
in santa monica in my first house i
thought he was going to miss it
but eight seconds to go yeah but in
those days i think was 47 yards
i think it was 45 but in those days it
wasn't so automatic these days
a 45-yarder they make it all the time
the kickers have gotten so much better
you wonder why
kickers are so much better uh because
you would think that there's no like new
technology or anything involved
it's a leg yeah maybe they're better at
strengthening their legs somehow through
advanced science that that was my way of
saying you were born and raised in
buffalo
that's right yeah and i i had never been
to a bills game
when that happened i had never been to
one i we we couldn't afford stuff like
that when i was a kid and then i moved
out of buffalo
and the first football game professional
football game that i went to
was actually the bills getting killed by
the cowboys in pasadena
because that was right in town and we
were actually ahead in that game for
about a minute and a half
and then jim kelly was knocked out and i
knew it was over
full disclaimer grew up an oilers fan
san antonio well
um then that bill's comeback had to be
painful so i've done a little bit of
research
uh some some interviews you've done in
the past and um
i i also grew up poor and i also had a
broken dryer
when i was a kid in my case it
it meant going to the laundromat
my mom had to hang the stuff in the
basement in the winter
and she would hang it on the line
outside the house in the summer
and that's actually pretty pleasant
because you get this kind of fresh air
kind of deal going but you know when
you're a kid you make lemonade out of
lemons
so we had down in the basement
we had a we built a maze out of
throws that we had to buy to cover the
couch because the couch wore out
uh-huh and we didn't enough money to buy
a couch because look if you can't buy a
dryer you can't buy a couch so what you
do is you buy
a cloth and you throw it on top of the
couch so it doesn't look so shabby
and then that wears out and so we stored
them up and we made mazes
in the basement to play tagging in the
winter time because in buffalo in the
winter
you know there's not a lot to do other
than you know snowball fight we we built
a hockey rink in our backyard
by just shoveling the snow and
when you shovel the snow because there's
so much snow in buffalo you get boards
essentially which is the old snow
and your zamboni machine is a hose a
garden hose and you just
and invariably and it actually works
pretty well yep
and so that was that was pretty good but
there was actually a bowling craze a lot
of people you know there's
been mania's over and over in financial
markets
and when i was a kid there was actually
a bowling mania if you can believe it
bowling stocks
were the hot area publicly traded
companies yeah
amc i think what made bowling balls or
bowling shoes or something still do but
yeah
and uh weirdly bowling was was super
popular
briefly kind of like tennis was i think
like in the 70s and 80s it's kind of
falling off
yeah what was your first job as a kid
i was a substitute newspaper deliverer
substitute yeah it was it was like there
was a kid
in the neighborhood my brother actually
was that kid for a while
that would have a paper route you know
you would deliver
door-to-door and but those whoever the
guy was the kid
that had the paper route they'd go on
vacation you know their family would go
on vacation somebody had to fill in
right and so that was my very first job
i i mowed lawns i don't know if that
counts
i ca that probably was a second job got
like three dollars for mowing along
three dollars yeah i shoveled snow for
the neighbor across the way
i can't remember what he paid me i don't
think it was three dollars
but he like but that you know i it was
just to get
walking around money did you like school
when you were young no i didn't like it
at all i was bored on my mind
i uh i would just stare at the clock
and i would do a thing like prisoners do
i think at least in the comic books or
on tv in the movies
where they do the days you know on the
side of the cell
you've seen that kind of depiction right
well i would do that watching the clock
how many minutes to go in the class
it was like so obviously i was
metaphorically feeling like i was a
prisoner
because it was so incredibly dull but
you probably got
great grades sure i got straight a's
sats sure i was
virtually perfect i was heard a perfect
score on my gre for math
for graduate school did you pick
dartmouth or did dartmouth pick you
um i went to my guidance counselor
in high school and my brother had gone
to princeton which was very
controversial in my family they didn't
they're very class conscious and my
grandparents
thought that that wasn't our place if
you will
and my brother finagled his way to claim
that he wanted to go
into architecture and princeton was
reputed to be great in architecture
and my parents wanted to go to
university of buffalo which is where my
my father and my
uncles went because it was cheap yeah
and
my brother didn't want to go there and
so he finagled this
this scheme i don't i think it was
largely fabricated that
since university of buffalo didn't have
a great architecture department he
couldn't go there
i don't think he took a single
architecture class at princeton
but i went to my guidance counselor and
i said you know
he goes where do you want to go to
college i said i don't know i want to
study like math
and he says well you know colgate's good
and dartmouth is good
and yale is good and university of
buffalo is actually good
math so i applied to those four schools
and
i didn't visit any of them before i
applied
i just applied to four schools and i got
in and
i visited them and i uh i really liked
dartmouth
uh just the feel of the place when i got
there
and so i decided to go there anybody who
knows you would would understand the
math aspect
yeah what was up with philosophy well
after uh the first term at dartmouth
i came back to buffalo for the winter
break and i went over
uh hung out with two of my best friends
from high school
and we were sitting in the kitchen and
they were talking about they had taken
philosophy 101
and they had coincidentally one went to
one went to uh
uh stanford another one i think he went
to princeton actually
ironically and they talked about what's
in the water in your town yeah they're
like there's a lot of smart kids they
like to fly
yeah they actually my high school spoke
about that for
years if not decades afterward my class
was like remarkably
uh i don't know maybe something in the
water like you say or maybe maybe
maybe it was the fluoride or something
but they talked about how they really
liked philosophy
and they went through some of the basic
things that you do in philosophy 101
like
you know choice versus fate and all the
sort of stuff
and i thought that sounds pretty
interesting so i started taking it well
it's not boring and i just took one
after another
and before i knew it i had enough for a
major in both math and philosophy
individually it was
it's just one of those things like doug
flutie said when he played for the bills
i remember him saying
i'm not trying to all i'm trying to do
is get a first down
i'm just trying to get a first down and
eventually you've just run out of field
and if you keep getting first down just
keep getting first down yeah you end up
you end up getting the touchdown
and that was kind of how i ended up in
math and philosophy i was i i liked it
and i kept taking it next thing i knew
i had a dual major what was
um what was the most pragmatic thing you
learned
in any any of your studies i mean i mean
very we're talking about very little
into the real world when i studied in
graduate school at yale for
uh theoretical mathematics the only
thing that we talked about that had
any practical application is we were
doing a combinatorics thing
that related to the rubik's cube in kind
of a metaphorical way that was it
but the way it works is the more you
study biology the more it turns into
chemistry the more you study chemistry
the more it turns into physics the more
you turn
you study physics the more it turns into
math and the more you study math it
turns into philosophy well i mean if you
think back to the ancient greeks that's
kind of
true isn't it i think it's really
literally true even to this day
that's kind of that's kind of the
sequence of it
and uh you know there's a lot of there's
actually phil
philosophy involved in math a lot of
people don't understand that because
they think of math as arithmetic or
calculus
but the whole idea of metal layers of
infinities is really philosophical and
it's interesting because a lot of this
meta meta infinity stuff has absolutely
no practical
application at all and it never will
because infinity doesn't exist right
that is deep so it's a weird study of a
of an intellectual precept that actually
is
completely flawed and this is this is
what i was studying
when i was studying mathematics at yale
in graduate school i wanted to
debunk google's and completeness theorem
which is one of the great
theorems people say of the 20th century
and basically
revolves around layers of infinity and
uh since the fee doesn't exist the
theorem is actually
not valid and i couldn't get
i got bait and switched i had an advisor
that encouraged me to do this and then
at the last minute they said you can't
do that here
we study the algebras you're as a
graduate student your
thesis is basically a chapter in our
next algebra textbook
and i just said i'm not doing this and i
left so
this is a little off script but is there
corruption in academia
um there's politics in academia which
i was so naive i really thought that it
was like intellectual purity
and you go and you become a professor
and everything's just incredibly
stimulating intellectually and
nobody has an agenda i think i was at
yale for
about a day when that myth got exploded
and i realized it's just another it's
just another
group of people that have all of the
dynamics that
groups of people have and the fact that
they're college professors
doesn't really change that dynamic at
all well i have to ask
my dad was raised in east haven he
actually went off to uh
he went off to uconn and then he
and then vietnam came but um but he grew
up in east haven
did you ever make it to pepe's pizza i
don't think so i don't think i made it
to east haven
no no pepe's pizza's in new haven we
would go into new haven to go to pepe's
pizza i didn't spend a lot of time in
new haven i
i lived out in the country really yeah
about
25 miles away from new haven because new
haven
i couldn't get an apartment it was just
the bottom line i couldn't i didn't get
i couldn't get uh student housing
because it was very limited for graduate
students right
and so i was forced to find an apartment
and there there basically weren't any
right maybe i started looking too late
too close to the school year
and so i just you know they have those
bulletin boards where people
hang up the piece of paper with the tear
out oh yeah type of deal and one was for
this house in cheshire connecticut
and cheshire is beautiful i drove up
there and i said this is very
inconvenient
locationally relative to school
but it sure is beautiful but you knew
how to you knew what to do with a snow
tire so
yeah well it was a big it was a
beautiful place i mean it was just
it turned out that the father of this
woman was attending yale law school
uh owned the house and had just
renovated it and
it basically had three suites in it kind
of and i shared it with these two other
yale students and it made it made
life kind of easy because there's really
nothing to do but study
because i'm out there in the country i
didn't have a tv or
i didn't watch it i think one of the one
of the women there had tv
and i had to study about 100 hours a
week so
there weren't exactly weekends hopping
into new york city no i
i think i went to new york city once um
but i just studied all the time and and
i i got burned out on it and i realized
that i
really there were only two places to go
with a phd in mathematics
and that's into the spy business nsa
you know or be a professor that's kind
of it and
i'm trying to picture as a professor
it's not happening neither well
i i was delusional and i thought that i
would be a professor i was i was
actually going to be a philosophy
professor but that
that got even more remote and so
uh i just decided one
i i almost never have a problem sleeping
but people
one questions you get a lot from
potential investors what keeps you what
keeps you up at night
i'm not going there nothing keeps me up
at night um
but there was one night at hill where i
could just i was up all night
i just couldn't because i was like i
can't do this anymore
i have to be a drummer i i just i didn't
know what i was
i was like my head was kind of spinning
i was trying to figure out
well i'm not going to do this math thing
so what am i going to do now it's like
so maybe i'll go to business school i
thought about that you know i'm like no
more school i
don't want to go to school anymore and
so i just decided
clearly musically inclined well i was
playing in bands and i played in band
while i was at yale that was the one
thing i did other than study
and the lead guitar player was all
hell-bent on coming to los angeles
because there was a red-hot music scene
in los angeles in the early 80s and
there were a lot of clubs there's a lot
going on and so
i didn't have anything better to do so i
said let's try that
and i got my junky chevy manza
with you know with the uh
stainless steel is it there's an
aluminum aluminum engine block i think
it was
and uh just drove across the country
announced you know five six seven days
whatever it was wow and uh all-day
driving
and i ended up crashing on the apartment
of our lead guitar player and
we started playing in bands we made some
records and stuff we were we were okay
we thought we were better than we really
were i think
and we played in clubs a lot and made
very little money doing it
so i had to get a real job and i got a
job working for an insurance company
because they love
math people and insurance companies for
actuarial stuff actuarials yep and
i what shocked me is i didn't hate it
really yeah i dreaded going in the first
day and it was
amazing after a few days i was like you
know i think this
this isn't that bad this is this
business world thing
isn't that bad and so
i uh was working there and
i this is story's been reported many
times and it's absolutely true i i was
living in hollywood i still
had the band thing going and all my
furniture
was was lent to me if you will or
donated to me by people i knew
so i had a cardboard box for a tv stand
i had you know chairs that were given to
me a table that was probably this big
that was for
to eat off of and so on and
i was thinking about um you know
actually then i started thinking about
getting an mba
and i even took i even took the gmat i
think is it called gmat
it was the gmat yeah gmat yeah i once
took the gmat the lsat and the gre
in a two-week window don't ever do that
yeah and i
i wouldn't do that no it was not good it
was
it's exhausting to take those tests they
go off all day i ended up with the nba
route
obviously but anyways yeah and so i was
getting second thoughts about i didn't i
didn't want to fill out the applications
for a bit i just wouldn't i'd leave him
in the corner i wouldn't get to him and
i sang
this is this is telling you something
you're avoiding this you don't want to
do this
and i flipped on the tv i had three
stations abc nbc and cbs
uh no cable or anything i had actually a
wire coat hanger
for an antenna because it was an old
black and white tv and
and the dial had broken off so i needed
pliers to change
the stations actually i know what you're
talking about i we had a tv like that
when i was growing up it was like this
big
and so i flip it on and i think it's on
abc
there was a show that i never really
watched it was called lifestyles of the
rich and famous
robin leech champagne wishes and caviar
dreams
and he says we have a special show it's
got that funny australian
english acts or whatever it is today
we're going to count down the top
paying professions and i'm like cool you
know this will be
let's figure it out make my list so
amazingly actuary was on the list
and they kept counting down and number
one was investment banker
and they say you have to work very hard
to be very analytic
but it's the best paying profession i'm
like i work hard all the time
and i'm extremely analytical so
i immediately went to the closet where i
kept the
los angeles yellow pages the it was
white and yellow it's the phone book
you know you don't see those much
anymore and i went to the yellow pages
with the intention of applying to
investment banking firms
but i was so naive i didn't i expected
that investment banker would be
in the yellow pages but it wasn't
there is no investment banker heading
but there was investment management
and i couldn't be bothered with the
details i said that's close enough
so i wrote a very aggressive cover
letter
and uh and had my resume and i sent it
to
everyone that had a bold face ad in the
los angeles yellow pages there were
about 20
20 of them and i was went
to my job at the insurance company
and i was using their uh equipment to
print off
my resume and this girl i was friendly
with comes up to me and says what are
you doing i said i'm printing off
resumes i'm going to be an investment
banker and she
looks at my list that i'm sending it to
and she says
and i was like i okay and
uh she said well i'll tell you what if
you're applying to these types of firms
i used to work down the street at this
one
and you can send it to this guy who's
with like an important guy there so you
get like an in
and his name's glenn wyrick so i added
them to the list
turned out that i only got three replies
from
all the ones that i sent uh one of them
was like the college rejection letter
where it's like a sentence you know and
another one was
hey we're a two-man shop you have a
fascinating background
but we can't pay you anything and i said
well that's going to be a problem
because
right right so lifestyles of the rich
and famous it turned out
that i ended up getting one from the
firm that this woman had told me to
give me the in and it looked like the
college rejection letter too
and i was so disgusted i just i didn't
even read it i threw in the trash
and then later that evening i the
curiosity got the better of me and i
went and fished it out of the trash
and it said we have had a large a large
response
to our job posting but
you can give us a call i mean don't get
your hopes up but give us a call
i was like job posting so some weird
serendipity had happened that i had
because you had no idea that there was a
job posting right i didn't know anything
about i was just sending it to this
to this referral if you will and i ended
up getting an interview
and i don't they didn't know what to
make of me because they were they they
i had no background whatsoever and
anything even related i
read one book it was called inside wall
street
and it's explained with a stock and a
convertible bond
it was very very breezy in high level
time not exactly liars poker
so i ended up getting invited back for
an interview
ironically with gron weirich because he
wasn't even one that sent me
the thing it was a very strange uh chain
of events
and so i sit there and goes you know we
could really use a quant like you
but i'm not sure how we would use you um
you know what do you think you'd be more
suited to
uh equities or fixed income
and i looked right at them and i said i
don't know what those things are
and his jaw almost hit the floor and he
said
equities they're stocks oh and
fixed income that's bonds and i didn't
tell them but i was thinking
where bonds i don't know what those are
so i but i knew what stocks were
and i'd actually been attracted to the
stock market when i was about
10 years old maybe 12 years old because
there was a roaring bull market
into the early 70s right and there was a
thing then that was a very increasingly
narrow market like we have now yeah that
was called the nifty 50. the nifty 50.
and one of the nifty 50 was xerox
and we owned my father owned xerox
because his brother
invented the commercial xerox copier and
was the head of research at xerox oh my
gosh
and so he had given him he said look
upper new york we're gonna we're gonna
be going somewhere with this
this this he actually made it
commercially viable he's he had 150
patents plus
my father's brother and so we bought
xerox and had participated in this
incredible run increase and we were we
were not we were
lower middle class and for the first
time ever
we actually felt we had a little bit of
money because this xerox stock had done
so well and my mother was
begging my father to sell it oh they
never did oh
and then the bear market came and at
that time
i was in eighth grade and there was a
small week-long thing about the stock
market as part of social studies
and it's kind of a assignment if you
will
everyone was supposed to pick a stock
and you know chart it or follow it day
by day
and so i picked xerox and it was i
remember it was like 153
and every day it dropped like two three
points
every day it was a brutal bear market
from 72 into 74. oh yeah
and it just kept dropping went below 100
went down to 50.
it went down and boy was my mother upset
about that because
she she didn't believe in that whole
stock market thing really and wanted to
cash out at the top
so that's how i learned a little about
stockmart but ever since that xerox
assignment
i was following the stock market and my
father had bought me
shares in pratt and lambert because he
worked at
a chemical company that was purchased by
pratt and lambert
and he had bought me a few shares and so
i was following that so when newspaper
would come
i would every single day go and check on
my pratt lambert stock
and i was at my grandfather's house when
the paper came one day
and i went i looked at it and it was on
the american stock exchange pratt
lambert
gosh and my and and my uh my
grandfather who had been a stock broker
in the 20s
in fact he he stayed in the stock market
even though he was bearish going to the
crash
because he felt conflicted how could he
keep
his clients in the market if he was
getting out of the market
and so he ended up he ended up still
being relatively wealthy
for that time but he says to me
why are you looking at the american all
that matters is the new york times the
new york stock exchange
i remember him saying that tonight and
so you know he had been
in that sort of but i followed it ever
since then and um
anyway i mean that's how i ended up i
got a job finally
in the bond department because they
needed a quant supposedly in a bond
department well i think i think he wants
maybe a little bit more important in
fixed income
yeah yeah and i was they were so
skeptical of my background that i was
hired for thirty thousand dollars a year
on a probationary period i think it was
60 days it may have been 90 days
and i spent
uh a couple of weeks in between before i
started
i had two weeks off and i've read all
the fixed income stuff
and one was called inside the yield book
which is kind of the
the bible of fixed income of mathematics
and stuff and i had two sections there
was a text
and then the second half of the book was
all these formulas and since i was fresh
off of a phd math program
i figured this is a good opportunity i
derived all the formulas from scratch
myself so and i figured everybody did
this
i so i walked here here's the black
shoals here's how the black shoulders
are so i walked in my first day on the
job thinking
you know i'm i'm going to be so
overwhelmed by all of the
depth of knowledge and all the stuff and
if in a few days i realize
i know more about this than anybody here
oh gosh
because it turned out that the guy that
was right the bond department
was a necessary evil they were really
were a stock firm stock manager but so
in those days a lot of pension plans had
what they call balanced accounts
of course and they gave it to one
manager both the stocks and the bonds
and they all were all focused on the
stocks so somebody had to take care of
this bond thing
and they hired an old crony of one of
the stock guys
and he was completely worthless as an
investment manager
he was awful i i mean he he always
acted exclusively on emotion clients
would actually
occasionally go over their statements
and say how can it be that you bought
this bond at this price
and there it never traded at that price
it's because
he actually bought the top tick and it
never even registered in like the
the tellerate database or whatever it
was back in those days gosh
and i thought i was doomed because i'm
like i'm trapped
in this department which is so
incompetently managed
it took me a couple of years to realize
that was actually a blessing because it
provided opportunity well sure
because i couldn't learn anything from
this guy except what not to do
but it meant that there was
a lot of opportunity if you actually
could provide some value let's bring the
godfather into this
closing business if you feel like
michael corleone and the got in the
godfather when you would close
business i read one of these old that's
not true
no no that what happened is there was a
uh
a line that i think i misremembered
slightly in
the movie the godfather which i've never
which i'd never seen i i'd actually just
seen
a clip of it i don't think i've ever
watched that movie all the way through
and there was a thing where i think
there was a wedding that's going on and
these people all come in and ask
the guy the marlon brando character for
favors and there's one guy's asking for
a favor
and i'm i'm misremembering but he says
something like
you come in here you ask for favors and
you don't even call me godfather
so what i i proloned that
concept whenever we would
have a trade idea or something and
there'd be a disagreement if we were
back when i was not fully in charge of
things sure
and would be like i think we should do
this and
someone else thinks they should do that
and if
it would turn out that i was more right
than the other people in terms of
i was right about 70 of the time they
were generally right about
49 which is the case with most investors
and when it would work out my way i
would say
you don't even call me godfather
[Laughter]
so i think the media
thought that was uh you know interesting
or
or or comical or whatever and they
even though you haven't seen the whole
movie that's exactly what
you were using it correctly well they
they hide the press hijacks things
into directions where they want to go
um the the thing that's the most
troublesome about the press is when
it's when they're they're almost i would
call it retweeting almost they're
re-reporting
so one reporter says something that's
quasi-true
and then somebody else hijacks it and
makes it in a completely different
context
which can actually make it literally the
opposite of the truth
but suddenly it gets a life of its own
and then it can go on that way and
this is why i i really don't like doing
any more print interviews
because i can't control the content i'm
much more comfortable talking to you on
camera
because at least you're not putting
words in my mouth you can you can try to
twist things around if you want to try
but
it's much more difficult than if you're
reporting i mean i
i had a a run-in with a major news
outlet i won't mention names but
i was at an airport i'm reading this
article and they had slipped my name
into it in a way that was completely
a non-sequitur and basically what
that by that time i was if you did an
article on me
you got eyeballs you you got top go you
got most red on bloomberg and all that
so
the reporters would just put my name in
things
and they'd try to somehow get into the
headline
because people do alerts and they want
to read the story so
they got my name in this headline and i
called up the reporter i'm like i have
nothing to do with this story
and he and he says um well i'm not going
to change it so i ended up
talking to the senior editor and i said
this story
has i have no place in the story and
that's bad enough but how you're using
my name in the story
is actually completely flips the context
and the meaning that you're giving
in the context of this article is
completely misleading
and he goes of course it is we're
intentionally misleading oh gosh
that's what he said to me and we wonder
why nobody trusts the media
he said we're intentionally misleading
and i just said well
i can't so i'd never spoke with that
news organization again
what would you say to um
to somebody who encounters adversity in
the workplace
they're young in their careers what's
what what were some things that guided
you
outside of being inserted into a
situation where you could really shine
which is great um but what what kind of
guidance would you give
people coming into the workplace
today which can be a hostile place what
i did i would not recommend to people
and that is i didn't take very much risk
with my career and i think that young
people
should take a lot of risk i'm talking
like in their 20s
okay and i was just focused on this
place where i was and
one of my um personality traits which
probably is a double-edged sword is that
i can be sort of an optimizer
so i'm in a situation and i optimize it
but i don't
i don't look for other doors right i'm
it's been optimizing
where i am and i i think that
i should have started my own company
in 1992 1993 at the latest
and i instead i just was one more day
one more day one more day until 2009
so many years later because you know
just just still plan don't get
comfortable yeah i i would i would
encourage people to be more planners and
more
proactive than most people are
comfortable being
but when i started double line i had
some young people that joined up that
had been working with me prior
and there was one um and i said you know
i
wasn't paying people anything until i
realized was told that that was against
the law
that california have to pay people some
minimum amount um
i we actually we were actually weren't
even really a company yet we were just
a a swat team trying to work together
yeah and there was one person who was 23
and i said how can aren't you afraid
coming here i mean you're not making any
money and and she said to me jeffrey
i'm too young to be afraid gosh to go
back there
but when i was 23 i think she was 23.
when i started three that when i was
i wasn't any kind of a situation
optimized but i certainly wasn't afraid
i got into a car
and drove across the country without any
idea
of what was going to be there uh when i
crossed the california state line
is the idea of failure cliche
are you a are you a turn the cheek
or an eye for an eye kind of a person i
am
best defined by my astrological profile
where massively scorpio if i i've
actually gone
i used to date a girl if his father was
a professional astrologer
and it's remarkable you don't hear this
every day it's remarkable how
this guy was helping people
with astrology it was pretty remarkable
so he did mine
and he's like old school he didn't have
a computer he was showered out by hand
this and this goes back this was way
back and this is back in the
around 1980 and every astrologers always
said the same thing look at my chart and
they go i've never seen anything like
this
i mean you've got this the sun and mars
which is
which governs scorpio and venus and
they're all on top of each other
you're just unbelievably scorpio
and they're right because you can kick
me around a lot
and i'll tolerate it up to a point
and then once you really step on me
you're dead
so that's how i am i roll with the
punches pretty well so i'll be
turn the other cheek for a while as long
as it's
you know just kind of nuisance stuff
right but then when you really
really kind of get to me
people really just kind of get dead to
me at that point surround yourself with
virgos
i've dated a number of virgos
[Laughter]
let's let's shift gears because
financial literacy is a big
problem it sure is in this country
actually financial illiteracy is what's
illiteracy that's what's taught
is if if that's possible it's possible
to teach illiteracy
i mean you start out illiterate you'll
be taught to read and
become illiterate but i actually think
most of
what's taken for granted is actually
taught illiteracy my best example of
that
is when the consumer spending data comes
out every month you know there's always
a big cheer
if there's a lot of spending and there's
a
extra loud cheer if that spending is
based upon a huge increase in debt
because what they say is oh this is a
wonderful sign because it shows that
that consumer is confident confidence
yes
the future and so
a huge uh pile of debt
gets twisted into a positive thing
and remember i used to work inside the
fed yeah you hear this all the time i
mean
that that you know like like home
ownership
is certainly preached but most people
never own their
home well that's what they just they
just home ownership
they're just renting the renting for
another 30-year lease
because even now we have huge
refinancing that's going on oh yeah
um we're actually back to almost 2003
levels for some of the cohorts that were
recently
recently written and these people
may have been i mean most of these
people are probably only a few years in
but they're people that are 10 years
into their mortgage
and then they re-up for another another
another 30 years you know i think i i
think i heard that
some almost impossible sounding fraction
of retirees actually have mortgages oh
gosh yes
which just shows you how incredible i
want to say it's close to 20
it's incredible uh how is that possible
that's
that's that's servitude that's not
retirement
so there's a lot of financial illiteracy
a lot
and and it keeps getting pushed i mean
there's a new there's a new class in
financial
literacy that was just rolled out i
think this year it's ever
smaller participation vehicles into the
stock market
there's this thing called slices now oh
where you can actually
buy five dollars of a stock right
and then i think there's an
advertisement on some financial media
where they say
you can be diversified with ten slices
for only fifty dollars
and and i think first we had the the
futures contracts
then there were the mini futures
contracts and then there's the
the many many contracts to allow a
broader base of participation from
less and less sophisticated people well
but i mean
are they learning anything they're going
to learn they're they're learning
how they're going to learn through the
school of hard knocks right
um what what's going on um at the top of
the stock market here in the united
states in february around february 19th
or so
there was a record of call by by the
little investor for these little mini
calls that you can buy now
there were seven uh seven odd million
contracts
on these and that was shattered any
record but um
presently at least a couple of weeks ago
that record was
totally taken out and there were more
than 12 million
it was not not a little bit taken out
that record it was shattered
oh robin so what they're learning they
think they're learning
that you buy the nifty 50 and xerox
takes you to 153
but when it goes back down below 40
that's when they're really going to
learn
oh yeah and this is this is the time i
was reading a story on the wires that
that
the guy who runs robin hood had to get
bulletproof glass
yeah because yeah well because investors
who had lost money were these people
don't even understand
that when you that that you can lose
more than all your money on some of
these options trades that's right
so that you know they could open there's
a there's an anecdote
i don't know if it's an urban legend or
not that somebody opened up their
statement
and it said negative 730 000 oh it's not
an anecdote it's
it's a real kid and apparently threw
himself in front of a train
yeah but i heard subsequent to the to
uh hearing that story that actually he
misread it
and he didn't and so it's doubly tragic
that but but that can happen well
but i i've got school-aged kids they've
never come home and said mom i'm going
to plot
a stock and watch it for a week or
whatever
it's it's the basic foundation's just
not there
well it's it's that's correct
but the problem's much deeper than that
the the problem is
that people don't understand the concept
of saving money
before you buy something i've talked
about this on my webcast there's a
incredibly funny but just a
golden nugget of a clip from saturday
night live
from years ago is when steve martin was
on the show oh gosh
and it's absolutely perfect it's
this couple is in the kitchen steve
martin and i can't remember
jane something or i think her name was
and and they're in the
kitchen table fretting over their credit
card bills and what are we going to do
where
all this debt and all of a sudden this
this guy shows up like off
comes on camera and he goes read my book
and he said because it's it's called
don't buy stuff you can't afford
and they're like what i don't understand
what does that mean
and look at page one
don't save money before you buy
something go
save money yeah and he goes like well
wait a minute
if i don't have the money but i want
something i can buy it right and he goes
no you can't fight really
yup and then he says but where are you
supposed to get all of this
saved money it's absolutely classic
sketch
yeah i'll never forget my my my
current doctor and favorite medical
doctor
once said danielle don't look at diets
if you want to lose weight eat less
he's less than exercise more it's pretty
simple yeah
and it's the same kind of that was it we
we were really
at a point at one point when i was a kid
where we were
really scratching to get by and
we were at the supermarket and we didn't
have enough money
and we had to put stuff back yeah and
i said to my mother because this was
there were no credit cards before 1970s
right
so here we are it's credit cards had
just kind of come
come around and i said why don't you
just put it on the credit card
and she just looked at me and she says
let me tell you something
never ever ever put food
on a credit card ever never borrow money
to buy food
because that's a slippery slope which
ends
potentially very badly i never forgot
that but also when i was a kid
there were no auto loans nope they
didn't exist you had to
save the money and go and actually buy
the car
now you can take seven years well it's
it's it's come this far it's because you
know
it's one of these things where everyone
knows that borrowing money to buy food
and
leveraging up on your car and you know
on that note it's funny i was listening
to the radio a while ago
and they were talking about how there
was a such a steep decline in prices of
used
luxury cars and i mean luxury cars
lambos ferraris right
and they were down like 50
in a year and this was before covet this
was when the economy was good right
right and they said you know the prices
have gone from like
i'm just making up numbers but 300 000
to 150
000 and i was like how could that be i
mean that there's
the economy's okay yeah and the reason
was
that they had toughened up on the
lending standards
for used car loans i was like
people are borrowing 300 grand by a
lambo
oh yeah their payments are like mortgage
payments
so it's one of these things where
everyone knows that this is
a bad way to go but it's all those
things where in the short term
there's a payoff and it's just like our
national debt it's just like
so many things that yeah yeah you've
been saying that
this is a problem for years and look
everything's fine
yes it's a problem in the long term
everybody says
but you know that could be a long long
way away but
what happens is you glue enough short
terms together
and all of a sudden the long term is
today and we're getting closer
we may not be there yet but boy we've
taken a mighty leap forward
this year in terms of heading towards
you know the debt cliff
do you think that there's because i'm
seeing it i'm hearing it i'm seeing
anecdotes
of people who are saying i've learned to
live with less
i don't know what i was thinking sure do
you think
that i think that's permanent do you
think that covett has the potential
to make saving great again
yes i think at least on the margin
i think i mean guess what 38 percent of
families with the hundred thousand
dollars
of income didn't have a penny of savings
coming into this right and
when they were staring into into the
abyss
of no savings and potential job loss
with without perhaps a safety net from
the government and they made too much to
get stimulus checks
they must have been really having a hard
time
because that's a that must be a really
scary thing
um and i think that could be a lasting
lesson
but i think i think there's more doses
of this lesson to come
i think that there's going to be a lot
of people
who are going to have to learn to live
with less they've already been
got the fear of god put into them that
they were staring into the abyss a few
months ago
but what about you need to say for a
rainy day and all of a sudden it's
raining what about the deflation that
would be caused by
a third of the labor force working from
home
i think i saw something that a third of
people want to work from home all the
time
yep well if they live in los angeles or
san francisco
why don't they just move to you know
some town in texas or something
and it's there's no taxes it's certainly
cheaper real estate
and obviously i'm going to pay that
person less
so that puts deflationary pressure on
all related
people in that whatever position that is
they're looking for for work and the
government seems
reticent to give money
to people that are more than double the
median household
income and those are people that
probably could lose their jobs or get
downsized
to a lower wage simply because there
could be pressure
for those positions i i think that well
companies are in a cost cutting mode
right now
they're going to cost there's no doubt
about it and the coveted thing has
provided
the work from home experience has
provided i believe i know it has for me
insight into sort of
the performance that is being delivered
by
individual employees we've spoken about
every company i know
i i have almost 300 employees we do our
best
to be better than average but of course
not everybody can be better than average
by definition you know and and so
i think we've got less fat than most
places
but there's got to be a lot of
organizations that have a lot of fat in
it
and that fat is being revealed it
certainly is welsh when he ran ge used
to lay off something like 10
is a policy a policy of laying off 10
every year just because you want to keep
people motivated you want to keep them
you know sort of a stick you know give
him a carrot on
on the bonus and a stick on the on the
fear
[Music]
but it kind of shows you that he
believes that ten percent is fat
yeah every year and so i think there's
insight that's being provided
and you know i think there's going to be
a lot less demand for commercial real
estate
oh gosh that's i mean if you think about
central business district cities in
america
that rely on public transportation and
how much
office property is in kind of the top 10
markets again that rely on public
transportation and there's just enormous
amounts
of and and this is this is the one asset
class nobody really talks about but it
is levered up to the hilt
yes it is yeah i mean the whole
commercial building thing
was just was it was in plain sight for
the last few years
just staring you in the face i mean i
just can't get over
how many hotels have been built oh gosh
i just can't get over it
50 of them are full service who's going
to
occupy these hotels everywhere i mean
i grew up we talked about buffalo new
york in the 90s there were no hotels
to speak of in downtown buffalo there
was i had to go there on business i had
to stay like a sheraton downtown it was
like a war zone it was terrible
you drive down that same street today
there's a hotel
like every block they're everywhere
every
every every small city in america has
been gentrified and since when
since i mean buffalo is actually a great
destination particularly in the
summertime it's one of the best places
in america
but most people don't think unless they
are informed about this through
through through a referral they don't
think i gots to go to buffalo this year
right yeah even though it's super nice
this time of year but these hotels
they're they're up and operating and
they're still building more
that's how private equity works yes on
volume
yes and you have
the higher the risk of these of these uh
projects
you get a little extra yield and the fed
has been more than
helpful in getting people to hold their
nose
and divert their eyes from the risk
and look at that extra yield i mean
there was a there there's an interesting
situations going on now because after
when the covet hit
there were all kinds of liquidations in
credit corporate credit junk
bonds everywhere it was much worse
market than the worst day of the global
financial crisis
in in march april there were literally
times when there was no bid
it lasted there was one night when there
was no bid for treasuries in the middle
of the night in asia that's right
and then the fed finally showed up after
the fed showed up money started pouring
into junk bonds
and uh corporate investment grade not so
much loans but certainly in the in
the regular bonds started pouring in and
that ended up dragging
a lot of other things slowly higher as
well asset-backed securities
mortgage-related things commercial
mortgages
leveraged loans in the last few weeks
there's kind of a dearth of supply
in those areas and people are doing
stranger and stranger things
in order it's just the opposite of march
where they had to unload everything now
they're trying to find things that have
a little bit of extra yield on now that
the fed
has the 10-year treasury down at 60
basis points and
the long bond at 1.3 and two bills at
zero
so today this very day there was an
issue
uh rolled out by amazon warehouse okay
now amazon is obviously a
a good company this bond is six-year
bond it's rated
single-a and they talked it
at a yield of three percent okay three
percent
and that was deemed to be so attractive
that the offering had ten
times the subscriptions
as the amount was going to be floated
it's coming next week so what that means
is that the yield is going to be
significantly less than three
because they're just going to keep
lowering the yield until
nine out of the ten people or nearly
that drop out it could
easily end up being two and three
quarters so we're going to grow amazon
is is a better credit but it's only
single a rate and
but industrial is the one place that
they've decided is going to be
the the chosen asset class and it's not
going to it's going to be the part of
the
commercial mortgage-backed space it's
not going to get hurt in the whole thing
i mean that
but but back up for a minute because
you know you're talking about a mania in
junk bond issuance what june was the
largest month on record
yeah but it was also corporate bonds
broadly i've broken all records
but it was also the highest month since
2009 for bankruptcies
what the hell is going on there's a
viewpoint that troubled areas
and it's not it's not articulated this
way but this is the way i think about it
troubled areas partially due to the
fed's policies
have been allowed to get so large
that there's a perception probably a
misperception at the end of the day
that the prospect of them on mass going
bad
is so frightening and so economically
devastating that it won't be allowed to
happen
that's it it's it's really the but it's
happening the airlines
it's very managed it's very but it is
happening we have like okay so today you
wake up and it's brooks brothers and
tomorrow it's surla
going and it's going to continue and
it's and this this this thing about
the the airline bailout you know which
you keep your employees for a few months
they've already been fired ahead of time
i know i know that's what i was getting
to and and we've given them
58 billion dollars when they used 45 and
a half billion dollars to buy back their
stock so in essence
we bought back their stock at a 25
profit except for one thing
we don't own the stock right we still
want the stock
we bought essentially their buybacks off
their hands and we don't even own the
stock
and but but what's happening right so
why did that happen well we can't
we can't let all these people go we
can't let lose all these jobs
uh during march and april well you're
going to lose them anyway because i've
already pre-announced the layoffs on
mass at both united
and american airlines and of course of
course there's no way out for them
uh under a capitalist regime other than
bankruptcy
that's the only way out i mean their
debt is absurdly high
just american airlines to pick one uh
their debt is so high
and and what we're doing and they just
raised two billion dollars
giving them is adding to adding to their
their grotesque debt burden relative to
their equity
so it's obviously again it's not a
solution it's just
a short it's again short term versus
long term
but you know what you know what we're
seeing though
is companies filing and
this this was the the holder of ann
taylor and lane bryant brands
so we're going to file yeah there's 3
000 stores involved we're going to
liquidate 1200 on day one
that's not the way you normally see
chapter 11 but there's so much
debt out there that there's so much
little
left when you do file what are you going
to get the creditors the one that the
history books will
really reference is the hertz equity
offering oh gosh
a chapter 11 company that's issuing
equity yeah
uh how is that possible well it turned
out it wasn't possible
okay they couldn't get it done so you're
getting you're getting to the crux of
the matter
has the fed permanently changed the
rules of engagement
will fundamentals have they negated
the ability for markets to signal
distress
has has has the fed won't in in parts
the market they
they have won for now anyway in part
other parts of the market
they have been appropriately absent
so we can talk about junk bonds where
the prices have been clearly propped up
the fed really went all in
april 9th i think they announced
corporate bond buying march
23rd but it was really april 9th that
changed the game and that's when
the etfs that own corporate bonds went
up like five
eight points in a minute and so if you
analyze
a basket of junk bonds i can't call them
high yield because
the yield isn't high so i have to call
them junk bonds the um
the price that the fed is in essence
paying for them
is clearly not a market signal it's
clearly a targeted price
right by the fed and it's probably
higher than what you're going to get
after you work through the bankruptcies
on a basket of high yield bonds so that
so in that in that sense the fed has won
in terms of
eliminating volatility in the corporate
bond market
but they haven't really won in terms of
investors
getting all their money back because
it's one thing to have a price
set every day it's another thing to have
a recovery right that comes out now in
other parts of our we mentioned
uh you know excesses and commercial
lending
the commercial mortgage-backed
securities market down in the capital
structure so the way it works
is you don't just buy a a loan to a
building that loan then gets
risk-traunched if you want right they're
like there's somebody's the subprime
loans yes somebody's holding
this the bag right down here and they're
probably wiped out i think everyone
knows that at this point
on certain parts of that market and as
you move up
you get to double b ratings which is a
high junk bond rating a triple
b rating which is a the lowest
notch of investment grade right those
areas have barely rallied
since the the awareness
of you know rent forgiveness and the
depths of the potential problems
um so i think you're actually getting a
signal there i
actually like that part of the market is
really dicey oh gosh it's really risky
so this is not something that you want
to do
do at home but this reminds me
of what happened in the mortgage market
for residential loans back in 2008
where it turned out that the market
was so overwhelmed that prices got
pushed down so far
that actually a professional which i
like to think that
that i am um in that sector actually
has opportunity it's just you have to
have a risk
risk profile that can take it right
because many of these assets they were
sold
the new issue at 90 at a dollar price of
95 or something
they went down to no bid literally but
maybe 40
maybe they're 50 today they haven't
rallied up that much because
the market is trying to just parse out
where that cliff is
and you have to do it if you're a
prudent person you have to look at that
without the most optimistic cases your
base case
right you've got to have a well you've
got what a 25
delinquency rate in hotels alone i mean
how do you
how do you price that risk unless you
are a professional right and
and you have to and what's interesting
about that
is thanks to the fed coming in and
putting
their kind of holy water on parts of the
market like triple a cmbs is doing great
long cash flow aaa cmbs sold today
at a yield of um 99 over
the 30-year so it was 2.29 percent
that's because it's got the halo effect
right over anything but
as you go down the capital structure you
actually get real prices
and when i talk to high-risk investors
and i say
this is something you might want to look
at they go oh no
no way i mean uh you know cruise lines
hospitality hotels and i go look
that's actually where you're getting
real prices somebody's gonna buy it
that's where the real prices are now
that doesn't mean you're gonna make
money right but you could make an awful
lot of money under a certain outcome
so you might have a good risk risk
reward profile but yeah so the fed
the fed has um certainly gone
where they've never gone before and that
is interesting to me because i'm sure
you're aware of the federal reserve act
of 1913
does not allow the buying of corporate
bonds and we have not amended that
and yet we're so we're in direct
violation right now i think the treasury
department has done a leveraged buyout
of the fed using enron accounting
so that's how i like to yeah that's
that's that's colorful but i i think
that's
off-balance i think it's kind of on
target
well it's kind of illegal yes but what
that tells me
is when somebody is now
doing things outside their charter it
means that they might do it again you
know it's like one of those things i
mean
if somebody if you look at their spouse
you know
it's sort of like gee maybe they will
again i mean
right if you look at the fine print
they're set up to buy
equities at blackrock they just haven't
announced the structure yet
they're awfully close aren't they but
it's well all you need is a few down
days and then they'll cross that last
rubicon
there's actually one more rubicon beyond
buying stocks that worries me the most
that's declaring that their liabilities
are legal tender
and not being a lender
through of this through this you know
facilitating this lbo as you call it
but actually saying we're just now
allocating money
that's the true money printing and the
true money printing
has a perfect record historically
of failing and you can go to rome
you can go to france in the late 18th
century
you can go to the weimar republic it's
all the same you go off
of any real money you go into a money
printing scheme
and what happens has been universally
correct through human history
that i can identify that is what
the people that were poor starve to
death the people that were middle class
turn into what the poor used to be and
the people who
are in the center of the money printing
mechanism
get ridiculously wealthy because they
make sure that the money trucks make
extra deliveries to their house
and this ends up enraging the starving
people
and the people that used to have had a
big haircut to their standard of living
and so they do things like march from
paris to versailles
in the pouring rain barefoot in in
numbers of the thousands if not tens of
thousands
to try to well they ended up taking uh
louis xvi antoinette back to paris they
didn't kill him right away
but they made him prisoners and that's
what ends up happening
but we're not i mean far be it for me to
say but
i mean watch the news we're not that far
we're getting closer
well talk to me talk to me about
inequality because
up until recently it was kind of seen as
this
area of philosophy it was just kind of
something to bandy about and talk about
as
if it was abstract in nature i think
it's pretty real
it's it's very real when you see that
bezos is pushing 200 billion
you know in in personal wealth and
i think what's what's unfortunate about
the inequality situation
is that there is
truth partial truth the idea
that these people that are on the
you know the the winning end of the
inequality
allowed don't pay hardly any taxes at
all and there is
partial truth to that unfortunately that
partial truth has most americans
even those that are upper middle class
believing
that nobody that has created
wealth for themselves has really paid
any taxes it's completely untrue
i had a massive tax increase from the
trump tax plan
my i had a huge tax increase because i
lost my deductibility
right for my state income tax and i'm
paying 13.3
to sacramento on virtually all of my
money so
i actually pay a huge tax rate
and and yet the perception yes i
actually
say this to people and they say you
don't even pay 20
and i say you how can you dictate to me
what what i'm paying in taxes i know
exactly what i'm paying taxes right and
it's over 50 percent
between state and this is just income
tax between state and federal
so the fact that mitt romney paid 14
percent in the year that he
used when he was running for president
that unfortunately
sells the partial truth as a universal
truth you know that he's
doing he's pa paying a ridiculously low
tax rate versus
somebody that's making a fraction of
what he's making
and that it leads to
the fact that that partial truth exists
and it exists particularly for those
that are mega mega mega on the side of
winning in the inequality right it gets
people angry well
what what's the better way what where
i mean where where do we start as a
country
i mean it's a really small question i
know
but i mean but but is it education
reform is it
is it i think education reform is
a glaring topic that
begs to be addressed because
you know when the civil rights movement
was really happening in the 1950s
and you had brown versus topeka board of
education
and it was about striking down
the the separate but equal plessy versus
ferguson ruling from
decades before you know the people in
the south
didn't want to get rid of the
segregation i think
largely speaking at least the
politicians that were in charge but they
made an argument that
carried a lot of water and it was aren't
your schools really segregated up in
boston too
aren't they really oh yeah i mean aren't
they really segregated in new york city
today aren't they really in los angeles
today aren't they really segregated it's
not by
exactly by by skin color so much but de
facto there's a lot of that in there
and it has a lot to do with opportunity
that needs we we need to
uh introduce opportunity again because
what we've done when the topic of
universal basic income
started to come up with andrew yang and
the like a lot of people thought this is
a cockamamie idea
we've been doing a version of universal
basic income since the 60s
it's called welfare right all right now
welfare was you could
sell it as being caring
but you can also sell it as being very
uncaring
because you're basically making a bar
again with a certain segment of the
population
will give you a subsistence type of
lifestyle and in exchange
you and your kids and your grandkids
will never have any real opportunity
there's never going to be a way out it's
a devil
it's a it's a bargain with the devil and
unfortunately
um that kind of
was lyndon johnson knew that
when he went gung-ho into it he knew
i think he made the statement that
thanks to the
the programs the great society programs
that certain segments of the population
would be democratic for decades to come
and he was absolutely right i mean it's
interesting kanye west
is provocative and he's acting like he
might be running for president
which is pretty interesting because if
he actually ran for president
i think he would take biden's chances
away
i think they would be gone kanye west
because it's sort of like in a weird
sense
the the the african-american community
is in charge of our elections they're in
charge of it because
for reasons that might be good or might
just be historical
their votes go overwhelmingly to the
democratic candidate right
every single time if they just split
their vote 50 50
there would be much more of a dialogue
that was going on right
but instead they're just taken for
granted and so in a weird sense
black community has much more political
power than they think
if they will just seize it and conway
west has
sort of kind of shown the light i think
that way
because if he actually one man one black
man said
i'm going to run for president i think
he controls the election
so conway wester isn't disenfranchised
he's probably the most
politically powerful person in this
moment
that we're experiencing right now well
talk to me about this moment
because i i think i speak for a lot of
americans
who don't feel like they have a choice
on november the 3rd
who who they don't feel
and they felt this way for a generation
this is not
about one man or the other it's not that
well it's because you had you you had
the republic rats basically take power
where you went from you know bush to
clinton to bush to obama
it's all the same thing nothing you also
had you also had democrats move over to
the side
of corporate america at the same time
sure so you had
you you had you had mixture on both
sides but at some point
that's what i'm talking about middle
income workers in america
people who are working making a hundred
and twenty thousand dollars in branded
as well the republicrat leaders
don't care about their the middle class
voice at all that's what trump tapped
into
he's kind of a republicrat himself
so but he was enough of a differentiated
product particularly because he was
running against
you know the the dynasty right
literally um he was such a
differentiated product that managed to
get them get
them over the hump but there really is
no difference there and
i think what happened is with the
republicrat
entity coming into existence suddenly
every politician in the so-called
democratic republican party
pretty much were influenced peddlers
used to be the republicans were
influenced peddlers and the democrats
were trying to stand up
for the smaller voice but that got
thrown by the wayside and
i don't think people identify that with
laser precision but they feel it
they feel right that something's wrong i
heard this analogy i thought was perfect
i think it was joe rogan which i've
listened to only one of his podcasts
but it was on this podcast and he said
it's sort of like
your immune system you know you're like
white blood cells are all gathering
somewhere they're not sure what's wrong
right but they know they just know that
something's wrong they can sense it and
that that's that's where we are and can
we have a third party
absolutely do you believe in long cycles
i believe
that if the election were 2021 instead
of 2020 there would be three parties
i just don't think there's enough time
right and kanye could probably try to
pull it off but
it's just so hard to register in all
these states and all these things
but when i look at labor force
participation
which fell during the global financial
crisis and then rebounded somewhat in
recent years
thanks to kovid it got down to 52 right
if that goes below 50 you got yourself a
third party
true you got yourself a winning third
party because you call
the locked out party the unemployment
part
the left behind part we're watching the
layoffs
climb up the income ladder it's going to
continue we're witnessing that right
it's going to get i think it's going to
get a lot worse and i think i think
that's going to put a real new kind of
fear
into what i call middle management type
of people they might realize
that you know
what they've worked towards the skill
set that they've developed
may not be in demand i remember i was
years ago it was in 1992
i was doing a road show for a closed end
fund we were doing
and it was such retail politics
we were driving around in rented white
tauruses from some reason they were
always a white tourist
and i was driving around with a dean
witter wholesaler oh gosh
and we would drive from smallish city to
smallish city
and pull into the dean witter retail
office
and their beach branch and there'd be a
team
of about 20 people there and we always
went and bought them donuts because
that's how they
began to come to the meeting by buying
them donuts and i would give them our
pitch and then we would
fold up the little easel thing put in
the trunk of the white taurus and drive
two hours to the next meeting we'd do
like six of these a day
you know every day of the week one of
those things where you wake up and you
have that
horrifying feeling which i think i only
had on these road trips
where you actually wake up and you go i
don't know what city i'm in oh gosh
i don't know where i am i'm in some
another another marriott you know
they're all look the same oh yeah
so anyway as you're driving those two
miles you know you got to
have something to talk about so this
dean witter guy was saying you know
you gotta understand things can change
really profoundly almost overnight
he said i had had this great gig i was
selling limited
partnerships like like payphone leases
the biggest rip-off products ever they
had a 20
load but they these guys were jamming
them to retail investors yeah
and he said i was literally got up one
morning
i turned on the radio and the news i
heard the news
and i looked in the mirror and i was
out of business he was legislated out of
business
by the stroke of a pen yep and he said
it was just so
life-changing because it was just
another day it was just another he'd
been doing this for years
and that that was all just taken away
from him well that could happen
to his people not just who are baristas
or maids in hotels this could happen to
these middle management people
who think that they're you know they
feel completely embedded
the system has been largely unchanged
for their whole career
confidence in job security right now and
prospects for jobs
are in different zip codes right
very different zip codes and they're
sort of like they start to realize
this could start happening to me and if
it happens to the guy in the office next
door
or you know the woman who they
carpool with or whatever yeah they start
to go
wait a minute yeah this might not be the
level place to stand that i always
thought it was
it's it's it's one thing to say that a
retailer that you
thought was going to go out of business
that that process was expedited it's
another thing to wake up and see that
wells fargo is going to lay off tens of
thousands of people
it's just they're they're different i'll
tell you
i'll tell you about personal experience
regarding that
we have a lot of wildfires in southern
california but most of them
are out in the pills and so on and
i would hear of all those wildfires and
i would just
it was always somebody else's problem
you know i i live near the ocean
and you know it's it's just not typical
so one day in january of this year late
january
it's a monday and i get up and i always
you know check what's going on
and an evacuation map for southern
california
well that's interesting i keep looking
at it and it took me like a minute and a
half to
finally accept the fact i'm in the
evacuation zone i'm on that map
this isn't some guy 75 miles away like
it usually is
i kept looking at no i'm in the zone yep
and so i'm like uh-oh
so we're like let's get a u-haul
and we spend like four hours and
putting stuff together putting in the
u-haul ready to go it turned out that we
were
at the edge of the evacuation zone and
we were
very close to being evacuated we never
were but it's that sort of
that crack of doom thing where you think
this can't that's somebody else's
problem
and i i think there will be growing
experiences an increase in the
experiences of that type of crack of
doom moment
so presumably there'll be band-aids
along the way
there there will be another iteration
of stimulus and we'll get something
before the election
for sure so let's weave
in sovereignty do you see
i mean i think the 30-year bond just had
the most incredible auction ever
yeah um but look further down the path
do you see the debt of the united states
i mean they downgraded china pitch down
excuse me downgraded canada i'm pointing
north
um do you think we'll get downgraded
no i i don't think you can
plausibly downgrade uh a
bond issuer who can pay in their own
currency
well they did it in what august of 11.
that was a mistake i i think that they
were
overstepping their boundaries i think
the rating agencies are supposed to
opine on the probability
of you not getting your money back i
don't think they're supposed to opine
on the purchasing power of the money you
get back and that's what they were in
essence doing i think
they were worried that the value of the
dollar would be put in peril but that's
not their job their job is to say
are you going to get your money back and
warren buffett was right on this he said
they should actually have upgraded it to
quadruple a
because you will you can absolutely
print your way out of it
you can absolutely pay or pay your debt
back will it be worth anything
well i think there's two there's two
possibilities that you
cut the promises to pay
which is very very politically
challenging the united states
now has about 154 trillion dollars of
unfunded promises to pay
seven and a half per times gdp there's
no way that you can pay that back and
purchase nobody talks about that by the
way
well one way to think about it is if you
decide we're going to fund these
and we know it's a long slog so we're
going to do it over 75 years
you'd have to take 10 percent of your
gdp in today's dollars
and put it aside that would be a 75-year
depression
yeah so it doesn't seem possible that
you can pay it back with
purchasing power so you either have to
default on them
which is possible you can default on
pieces of social
security pretty easily just raise the
age just raise the age
raise the age from present age to let's
go crazy and say 80.
that solves it solves the problem yeah
no well there's
see all that actuarial stuff is really
handy that's right
it solves the problem but the problem is
so solvable
and yet you have to be
it's like chemotherapy i mean you've
gotta you've gotta be
fearful of a worse outcome and that
hasn't happened yet
well okay so let's weave
ever so briefly the small subjects of
china and covid
into this discussion and reserve
currency status
and our place on the global stage their
place on the global stage
116 countries joined together
with australia to demand an independent
inquiry
into the source of the virus so it's
that's theater okay i mean it's not
gonna make it go away it doesn't change
anything
but china has one really big advantage
over a
system like the united states has and
it's also a huge disadvantage
but everything's always a double-edged
sword there's no and so
their big advantage is they're an
autocracy that's a big disadvantage for
human rights
but it's a huge advantage for long-term
planning
because you don't have to worry about
somebody
scuttling your plan four years from now
and starting another plan
so i had lunch with henry kissinger
years ago and he loves to tell these
stories of his
rubbing elbows with world the world
powers
and he told me that he had a dinner with
the leader of china
and this was many years ago and the
leader was impressing upon him how they
have a hundred year view
we have a hundred year view here in
china and it's fine with us if it takes
a hundred years
for us to officially have taiwan back we
don't care one bit
and then kissinger said that he
subsequently had dinner with the same
guy
30 years later or or maybe his successor
at this time
and he said you know i was told 30 years
ago
that you can wait a hundred years for
taiwan
is that still the case can you still
wait a hundred years and he said
well that was 30 years ago so we can
wait 70 years see
right but they have that plan they have
i mean they hate it is reserved currency
status part of it they have gold of
course they want reserve currency status
is military in there somewhere of course
um
yes they're they are obviously ascendant
they speak
i've i haven't been to china in a long
time i went there
from 2005 to 2009 every year
i can't tell you how much it changed
over that
short period of time i went there and i
met with like
real senior people in finance you know
bank of china people like head guys or
deputy head guys
and the first time i went there i got
one type of reception
and it was it was they were a little bit
docile i would say
and then 2009 the reception was
confidence strength they were they
they were sort of like well we'll see
what happens we'll see what they
they had a lot they had a lot of moxie
that they didn't have in 2005 and they
still this is this is 11 years later
it's got to be 10x oh sure what it was
in 2009. and american companies are
discovering that
even though they've that they've got a
lot of lip service that
that the door is only partially open and
that they'll it's
it's just i mean and whatever 11 years
ago that they weren't they weren't
17 18 of gdp american consumers
are waking up to the to the
it's the reality that we've borrowed a
ton of money to buy
plastic trinkets from china on vendor
financing
and we've even gone so far and people
woke up with the kovit
they've gone so far is to have one
source of certain essential things and
that's china
for supply chains right and other things
24 of us
auto supplies how about pharmaceuticals
we're talking about covenant gosh
right and so they're starting to realize
that what was such a great deal with all
this
cheap goods where the debt that you were
incurring
to buy it was an abstraction it was on
the government's balance sheet or
you know they're starting to realize
that they're tied together it's pretty
real
and as they the building blocks of
knowledge
are starting to fall into place much
more than where you were four years ago
on how the comp how the
the how the system
got to this place by
short-term feel-good things being the
priority
but the land that it takes you to
is one that must ultimately fail
so on that happy note um if your
joe q investor
and you're being told that it's going to
be a v-shaped recovery
and that everything's going to be fine
um
i don't see how anyone can accept that
as as
as a logical statement when does this
end you cannot
take 20 of the labor force
and have them not produce anything
and there's no consequences nothing
happens
everyone's lifestyle is the same nothing
changes
no that that's that's not mathematically
possible so at some point they'll pull
the extra stimulus they'll
they'll mortgage forbearance will go
away rent
moratoriums will disappear
uh eventually they must i i think
they're going to last a lot longer than
they're letting on
because it's kind of got the tiger by
the tail they don't want to let them go
there's no there's no cap on the debt
ceiling until june of 2020.
powell says our ability
to quantitative ease by bonds is
infinite
yep that's a that's a pretty bold
statement
i mean it was like
in the days when there were actual live
telephone solicitors and not robots
they would actually call up and your
dance back in days when you have
landline this is years ago this guy
calls up he's
trying to hard sell me on something he
was he was a guy
he was an indian accented guy and i go
look
i have absolutely zero interest there's
no chance of me buying this thing
you're just completely wasting your time
and he goes very strong opening position
and i i almost wanted to buy the thing
from the guy because that was that was
just a great
story that was just a brilliant right
but that's what paul just did i mean
very strong opening position
right an infinite well there's no
infinity there isn't he means that
there's no ceiling
right so so what's an investor to do to
protect themselves
is there any i mean there has to be an
end game here i'm sorry but
i i i hate to give a financial media
type answer but
because but in this case are you going
to say diversify diversify diversify
yes and i hate that answer because
that's that's an answer
that people give to hold hold
uh their clients hands through rough
times right right but in this case
since there's such a binary outcome that
there could be confiscation
and there could be debasement both and
it's really
almost a policy choice but it seems that
one of those choices
is going to have to start to be at least
discussed
seriously and polite company and so you
have to
i would say diversify you have to
barbell right
barbell so you have to own
things that will survive debasement
and hard assets yeah hard assets and you
have to
own the the reason to own stocks
would be that at least if we're going to
add two zeros to the price of everything
you probably had two zeros the price of
stocks too right
so at least you're probably kind of
floating along okay
the idea that you're going i mean i saw
somebody
you don't mean that stocks are not going
to correct
you can always manipulate them the fed
has manipulated the corporate bond
market
i i think absent manipulation that the
stock market would be
uh in serious trouble unless there was a
a true money printing exercise i mean
the stock market
has a pe that is at such nosebleed
levels relative to
sober earnings and as we all know all of
the earnings growth the past five years
is the super six
fang alphabet and all that stuff
microsoft away from that there's any
earnings growth at all in the last five
years
which means that earnings are actually
down
if you hadn't had a tax cut and if joe
biden wins
and he promises with glee he promises to
reverse the tax cuts
yeah well how's that going to affect the
pe of the stock market
it's it's going to make it not just 25
on forward earnings
and we're getting within spitting
distance of the 0 highest ever forward
pe
and you know so that would be a really
big problem but it's
it's the most narrow market ever and uh
so it you know
should you own zero no because it's one
of those barbell
weights but i i think um
i think hard assets and that that's not
very good advice to
john q investor because john q investor
doesn't have any savings
right and you know hard assets require
liquidity to
get people that are buying 50 of slices
they're not going to get rich on fifty
dollars of slices they go up 10x which
i i saw a guy on a financial program
very recently
it was actually june 8th which was the
top
so far of of this uh rally
of the stock market and um it was june
8th and there's actually a guy who said
i've been bearish i've been wrong
i was too bearish too conservative in
april and i've reevaluated
i think this is the best buying
opportunity of my career
i i just i had to rewind it and watch it
several times because
i can't believe it it really at
a pe of 25 this is a better buying
opportunity than mark 209
when the pe was single digits right i
mean
that kind of mentality is they'll
they'll learn the hard way look you've
given me a lot more time than i was
planning on so this has been
a real treat i have one last really
really hard question for you okay
are the bills going to win the nf nfc
east
they they almost assuredly will if
there's a season and
that's what makes me so frustrated
because we suffered
through 17 years of no playoffs for the
bills
and then we kind of side doored in
through a miracle play by the cincinnati
bengals
and we really deserve to be there but
then we we did deserve to be there last
year we actually
earned it and the bills are clearly
ascendant
and they actually look like one of the
best teams in the nfl and
isn't that just the perfect torture for
the long-suffering bills fan that when
you're just about to start on an upswing
they kneecap you and you know pull the
chair out from under the season
and there isn't one but i i think almost
assuredly the bills would win the afc
east
uh if if there's a season well um i'll
be cheering for them
i'm not a big cowboys fan so um thank
you thank you so much for your time
i really appreciate it all right go
[Music]
bills you